okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the biological extraction of
metals the supply of some metal rich
ores such as copper ore is limited and
the demand for lots of metals is growing
so what we're trying to do or what
scientists are trying to do is come up
with ways that first of all at
economical economical which means
doesn't cost much money and can extract
metals from low-grade ores that's ores
that don't contain that much of
particular metal so there's two
different types of biological extraction
that we're going to look at and they are
called bio leaching and fighter mining
so we never see bio we know it's to do
with living things so both of these
processes involve living things process
one is called bio leaching so remember
the the way of a member and which ones
which is Bay's for bio and bio leaching
uses bacteria which also starts with a
babe so let's imagine we have an ore
which is copper sulfide I need to
extract that copper from this all in
order to be able to use it so what can
be done is it could use bacteria in
order to do this now what happens is the
bacteria get energy from the bonds
between the atoms in that all this
separates the atoms from the ore in the
process and as this happens a substance
is created which is called leachate it's
a liquid called leachate this is why
it's called bio leaching because we
produce leachate
so once we've produced this leachate
which contains these copper ions there's
two different ways of then extracting it
so one is displacement so remember what
we're trying to do is get copper all by
itself so what we can actually use is a
more reactive metal than
copper and the one that's often uses I
am particularly bits of scrap iron that
aren't particularly useful so by using
iron it displaces the less reactive
copper so we can get copper all by
itself and so therefore we've succeeded
in extracting it the second thing that
we could do to leachate is a process
called electrolysis because within the
leachate there are copper ions so
electrolysis in electrolysis we have two
electrodes a positive electrode the
negative electrode and we pass an
electric current through them this is
where we put the leech a so both of
these electrodes are within the leachate
okay so what happens is the copper ions
which are present within the leachate
will go to the cathode that's the
negative electrode because opposites
attract and this is where we can collect
our copper so that's the first method by
only Qing the second method also using
living things is called phyto mining and
this is clever
so in phyto mine in what we have is we
use plants so we have let's say we have
a plant here and underneath the ground
obviously of plants we have their roots
so in phyto mining let's say we again
want to get copper what we do is we'd
plant these plants in a region where we
know there's a lot of copper or copper
all now what happens is little
quantities of this copper will be
absorbed through the roots of the plant
and therefore it then be transported
throughout the plant and be stored
within the plan so if we've got
thousands and thousands and thousands of
these plants all taking up bits of
copper we've now got copper stored
within them but it's really difficult to
just take that out so what needs to be
done is all of those plants they get
burnt in a big furnace so here's the
plants remember this is thousands and
thousands of plants all containing
little bits of copper we'd burn them
okay so what we're left with afterwards
is we're left with a big load of ash but
within the ash there'll be lots of bits
of copper loads and loads of copper so
we can see again it's a biological
extraction because of living thing this
time as a plant rather than bacteria and
we've been able to get our extract our
mess and get our metal at the end so
just a quick recap biological extraction
of metals try and cheaply get metals
from low-grade ores those odds that
don't contain much metal bio leaching
uses bacteria which creates leachate the
the metal can then be extracted using
displacement with a more reactive metal
and electrolysis or electrolysis and
fighter mining involves plants absorbing
the metal through their roots burning
the plants in a furnace and then the
metal is left behind within the ash
thank you very much